yes one of the things this show is
celebrating
is that raw this is going to sound fake
but i mean it that raw
weird weird side of humanity yes you're
we're riffing maybe you say something
and you go i went a little squirrely
that's life i don't want to
pre-interview you i don't want to let
you're not going to leno my balls
yes i'd rather have footage that when
we're long dead they'll go there they
are that was them that was them that was
them and you know what awkward and all
and that's the best part is that i can
look at you and say you're a stone cold
[__]
and it's fine it's it's like it's
acceptable
it's like cold [__] you're a stone cold
[__] i could have taken a 45 minute
break when you were like i could look at
you and say i'd go in the back 45
minutes right never would have guessed
that you were about to say
called [__] i didn't see it coming
either tell me
technique we're going to get to your
comedy chops because i'm such a fan
you're so funny but let's let's go where
we are but we sort of wrapped up the
leno thing so i'm going to say we're
moving on
you met her on third rock from the sun
she did a guest star yeah is that
correct yeah
and then we entered into a
flirt immediately maybe that's
uncomfortable yeah no we did well she
she had been um
uh i talked to her last week we're still
like are you friends yeah can i do this
is this too like well for radio like a
thumb up in russia thumb up
that's right
that's correct
yeah
well but she had been previously married
to dennis hopper
wow
and so around what era hopper
uh she was the speed
yeah were they together during speed she
was well she was the uh what's the
basketball movie um the uh
hoop dreams
hoops
hoop nightmares you know i'm gonna be
honest with you dennis hopper is one of
those guys yeah there's a lot of actors
where we're like oh my god dennis hopper
yeah they got him for that show and i'm
like this is the first thing i've kind
of seen i've seen this like you know
they're legends but yeah kind of like
you haven't seen
a drugstore cowboy or something and
you're like no i haven't
seen it no no i haven't seen it yeah
yeah everybody makes you feel stupid
exactly yeah so she was married to
a water world water world hopper time
hopper okay so i just thought that like
his legend for misbehavior i thought
well
how bad can i be
is hoppered legendary a misbehavior yes
a squirrely mm-hmm really like an insane
asylum
level like a nuts a lot of drugs a lot
of craziness lots of crazo lots of grazo
raisins so i just thought in what i was
what flavor crazy like like gary busey
like i watched a movie on my teeth last
night and then he does the scene yes
like just kind of nut so yeah
like beauty beauty level busy not uh
pervy
just kind of nutty no no but a little of
that
yeah all of it beauty flavor
um i don't know what flavor that is is
that like grape
oh my god if you see gary busey drinking
a soda you know it's great i saw him at
bill maher's house one time and he no no
but mario he's got more yeah and he he
waved at me and he was on the opposite
side of uh
like a very clean glass window
and then gary busey walked into it like
a bird
the sound of those male kira knightly
choppers banging into plate glass and
and bill mark comes out and goes new
rule don't put gary near the big old
window yeah and meanwhile like uh
like
florence henderson is just hanging out
like from the brady bunch you're like
you know and she's talking to like the
the
like
like some porn star ah it's just can i
you know what you do if that happens if
i'm bill maher and you see smears my
glass and there's just like a you know
kind of like a waxy what's your reaction
imprint i save it like the shroud of
turin is what i do
i banksy that [__] i put plate glass
around it and i go would you like to see
my busy image then you just replace the
window oh my god of course i go this is
where busy waved at french steward past
the girl from brady bunch talking to a
porn star
and abusey you ever turn abusey because
that shit's worth 89 grand a minute you
start to wonder what was worth what like
at certain points of your life where
like yeah i could have i could have
turned abusey you could have turned a
busy into a fat profit a fat profit i
mean just the absurdity oh that's our
new band fat profit yeah do you want to
what do you play bass i'll play anything
all right but not well but i'll play
bass i like that you guys because
they did fine except except for they
died
um
i just can't oh chili vanilla i love it
i apologize
vanilla coke
that's my favorite drink that's the new
flavor yeah yeah it's it's how many
calories so there's a zero yeah
there's a there's a ruse in it
for those of you who aren't our age uh
millie vanilli yeah a lip syncing duet
would you call them a duet i would call
them a duet can you join me in this yes
baby
do you remember the song yeah don't
forget
look
i've dropped
four times i don't know why you're doing
this to me i'm a nice man
[Music]